my name's miles aka the
guy and today i'm going to show you how
to professionally clean
a hot tub all right
this is probably the worst hot tub i've
had to work on there's literally
slugs spiders the water's black
and the smell is just disgusting
so the first thing i've done when i got
there was taking the cover off
for the actual job was yet to take the
cover off
inspect it see how bad it was we took
that off and stood it up on the grass
and that got jet washed
um and brushed down and there's a lot of
like creases in the cover so
there's slugs in there as well still
trying to hide and like
sort of stay in their home but they all
got cleared out so it was mostly water
with the jet wash
um and then you had like a little bit of
um cleaning solution
uh with the cover that took around an
hour to clean
[Music]
on the side there's a lot of like black
markings like
slime and dirt and there's still a lot
of slugs sort of like
um slivering around 100 slugs on this
hot tub
and the guy said he hadn't used it for
like 10 years
so i just started off with a jet wash
and they sort of got jet washed away at
first there was like so many and i'm to
be honest with you i don't really
fancy picking up slugs so
so the white tube there that's connected
to my submersible pump which i'm using
to
pump water from the hot tub down the
drain
so i've got the broom out um because
you've got where where you sit down in
the hot tub it's quite
it's a bit like a bowl so it'll hold a
lot of water and what i'm just doing is
just pushing it into the middle so the
submersible pump can
drain out easier
[Music]
at the bottom of the tub you just had
like a little bit of dirty water
and a little bit of grit
so underneath here you've got the main
circulating pump you've got the heater
for the
hot tub all the pump equipment's kept
underneath the hot tub
so i pulled the panel back and which all
needed to be cleaned out as well and i
used the hoover to get all that
so hot tub flush is a chemical which you
will pour
into your intruder where the filters
usually sit
and then you turn on all the all the
jets in the hot tub
so yeah once you put the hot tub flush
in and it starts reacting
with all like the um fats and everything
that's caught
up in the in the tubes inside the hot
tub
it curves like a foam and then you can
also see in the foam you can see the
dirt which is coming out of the
pipes as well so you can see it's
working
once it bubbles up you can um get a net
and just net them out so they don't
because what happens is it will start
sticking to the sides
because it's like an acrylic material
so it will stick to the sides um and if
you don't scoop it out you'll have to
then scrub the sides again
um so it's just easier just to get the
net net out the foamy bits and all the
dirt on the foam
it'll make it easier for yourself
um so i've got this hot tub filler here
and it's
looking really black there's a lot of
dirt all over it and i'm going to give
it a rinse down just to clear it so it's
filtering properly again
most pools have sand filters whereas hot
tubs have cartridge fillers
so what happens is obviously while the
filters are collecting the small
particles if you don't take them out
and rinse them your wall will start to
go cloudy
uh so it's basically just dirt and then
obviously anything that comes
off like your body um like
dead skin anything can get caught up in
the filter as well so
you can rinse them down with your garden
hose and then you can spray them with um
filter cleaner which just disinfects any
bacteria that's on them
and then put them straight back into the
hot tub and
then they're ready to go again
on hot tub you can get like a little
floating dispenser
and it just floats around on the water
just slowly releasing
chlorine or bromine
uh that's a chemical test kit
and on the left will be to test for the
bromine or chlorine level
and on the right i am testing for the ph
level
you're looking for the middle color
which is around 7.2
so with the hot tub it was looking after
i'd finished with it
looking brand new nice and blue again um
the customer was really happy with it
and
it just looked like a new hot tub rather
than what it did like
five hours ago that was definitely the
worst hot tub i've ever worked on
and actually seeing the final product
and with it nice and blue
water in it again nice and clear and
everything working on there
i was pretty happy with that
you